Jenny Lisa jisoo and Rose even if you
didn't know their names before Coachella
23 you now know all the words to type a
girl and pink venom by heart and have
your favorite bias set as your
background pick on your phone often
described as the biggest girl group in
the world blackpink is the most
successful International K-pop girl
group of all time and not surprisingly
their bodies and diets make up a whole
genre of content in the community of
K-pop fans so wish me luck as I attempt
to live like singing dancing
20-something Superstars and attempt to
eat like blackpink for a day hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video I'll be discussing the
diets of K-pop girl band blackpink and
using their alleged meals to inspire a
balanced day of Abby eating for myself a
quick disclaimer that we will be
discussing a very low calorie diet plus
disordered eating behaviors and also
showing very small body measurements on
screen so please feel free to skip this
video if it doesn't feel supported to
your journey and if you are not already
subscribed please help a girl out hit
that subscribe ring that Bell so you
never miss out and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen
okay let me hop in here super quick to
talk to you about my sponsor today hiya
so as a dietitian and Mom I take my kids
nutrition pretty seriously and by
seriously I guess I mean something some
days they live off of grapes and air and
I try not to break a sweat kids are
unpredictable especially when it comes
to their diets so leaning on a good
quality supplement helps to give me
peace of mind and helps ensure that they
get what they need I'm really picky
about supplements especially the ones
marketed at kids I typically avoid
gummy-based vitamins for kids and adults
alike because they are notorious for
under delivery of the stated vitamins
plus a lot of them are pretty high in
sugar but Haya is a chewable multi
formulated with 15 essential nutrients
like vitamin D B12 zinc Foley and
calcium that's fully vegan allergy free
and sweetened with monk fruit it arrives
straight to your door on a monthly basis
alongside a refillable glass jar that
comes with a really fun sticker pack
that kids can personalize and decorate
and then every month after you get a
refill pouch of Fresh Vitamins which is
a huge bonus for the environment too so
if you want to try out High out yourself
check out my link in the bio or you can
go to hihealth.com Abby to get 50 off of
your first order oh boy there's a lot to
unpack but straight up the normalization
and celebration of extreme body
expectations and problematic eating and
exercise behaviors in K-pop culture is
terrifying as I discuss this in a lot
more detail in my K-pop video right here
so definitely watch it right there but
in short when I reviewed the diets of a
bunch of popular female Kpop Stars I saw
a very common theme of super small
portions of super low fat meals that
clocked in between 300 and a thousand
calories there are compilation videos of
adults ripping food out of these young
girls hands and careless blogs mapping
out these young women's body
measurements and comparing the
circumference of bandmates waists it's
also interesting that if you search
blackpink Die on YouTube most of the
thumb nails are just of a faceless
before and after body shot of their abs
all I know is that we're going to have a
lot of massaging of these meals to do so
Abby good luck so no mention of coffee
preferences on any of the K-pop blogs
that I read though since this is like a
K-pop themed day I figure it would be a
good excuse to try out the kind of
delgona coffee trend of early 2020 which
somehow I never even attempted myself
dog on a coffee I started in South Korea
which I feel like most tick talkers
missed so let's give it a go instant
coffee sugar hot water gave it a blend
add our milk and give it another whip
this is dangerous oh oh oh I think
that's where we tap out
hmm
this tastes like an adult Frosty and I
am here for it
but your girl cannot live on caffeine
alone so let's talk breakfast I'm not
gonna lie a lot of the blogs that I read
suggested that the girls have a few
apples for breakfast and I shut that
idea down really fast so for a slight
upgrade keyword slight we're gonna go
with bandmate Jenny's pick
Jenny often reaches for Bland foods like
porridge with no salt added absolutely
no salt added to avoid getting bloated
before shows dear God now argue with me
in the comments but oatmeal without salt
is about as close as eating paper mache
paste as one could come Pape mache
balloon trousers I'll see you next time
so in complete protest I'm going to go
in the other direction and make the most
flavorful and well-seasoned porridge of
all time while I grab some ingredients
Abby can you talk about whether or not
salt is in fact bloating okay so let's
set the record straight bloating is from
air water attention is from water and
excess sodium doesn't cause IBS like
bloating typically it causes you to
retain extra fluids however completely
cutting out sodium and depleting your
electrolytes is a recipe for performance
disaster nausea vomiting fatigue muscle
cramp seizures and even death have
occurred on stages due to electrolyte
imbalances yeah if bloating is a concern
avoid lots of high FODMAP or even high
fiber foods before a show drink lots of
water and maintain your normal
electrolyte intake
a little bit of avocado oil green onions
a little garlic a little ginger some
garlic quick little stir then we're
going to add our quick oats and some
bone broth to cover and Popple it in
while that's cooking I'm just going to
fry up an egg oh
nice
nice now a quick little sauce here we've
got some Greek yogurt some lime juice
and one of my favorite ingredients of
all time gochujang which is a Korean
sweet and spicy chili sauce
awesome and a little maple syrup
so I've got I've got leftover baby bok
choy that I just stir-fried in a little
bit of tamari last night I'm gonna throw
that down we've got our delicious runny
egg a little drizzle of our gochujang
sauce some cashews and a little Sesame
on top and the most important step the
poke
you just want to get the tip bro what
are you talking about man of the fork oh
yeah baby so to recap we've got protein
in our egg and in the bone broth that we
used for cooking high fiber carbs in our
oats plus some extra fiber in our veg
there and lots of healthy fats in the
nuts and seeds oh and we'll serve with a
little apple to make our friend jisoo
Happy
oh oh
honestly Savory oats it's where it's at
this year I'm telling you well that was
a super satiating filling breakfast and
thank God for salt so I got lots of
great energy on board to help move my
body so the girls had been quoted as
saying that they love Pilates style
workouts but they also spend most of
their day doing vigorous work
at on stage like Lisa's being quoted as
saying she dances 12 to 15 hours a day
I'm gonna pass on that so that I don't
like pass away at party sounds great to
me so while I do a little workout Abby
can you like go over the risks of
putting yourself in an extreme calorie
deficit like this yeah as a healthcare
provider I see a lot of red flags number
one dehydration and electrolyte
imbalance as we already discussed along
with General malnutrition two the risk
of female athlete Triad which is often
characterized as disorder eating loss of
menstrual cycle and osteoporosis studies
suggest that consuming just 22 to 42
percent fewer calories than needed for
weight maintenance can impair
reproductive function not to mention a
loss of bone mineral density could mean
that a single slip on stage could
completely end their dancing careers for
good and finally of course I'm worried
about the psychological damage of this
grueling diet and exercise regimen you
know research suggests that professional
dancers are three times more likely to
suffer from eating disorders compared to
the average population so while these
girls may be viewed by their management
team as like a workable commodity right
now they clearly are not thinking about
their career longevity and the risk of
burnout or injury like so many other
K-pop Idols before so go easy there Abby
your team still needs you to be healthy
and sane so according to a bunch of
sources that I read the girls eat a lot
of salads for lunch especially before a
show I specifically saw avocado salad
come up quite a bit which I love but
Lisa also is apparently a huge fan of
salmon poke which is a lot more
satiating sounding than just like
straight up lettuce and avocado so I
figured this would be a good time to try
out another Tick Tock craze Emily
mariko's salmon Rice Bowl but of course
with little Korean twist you've seen the
tick tocks let's do it we've got some
leftover rice break it up break it up
I've got some canned salmon because we
always have Cam salmon Nestle in an ice
cube and top it with parchment pop it in
the microwave and I'll meet you back
here all right a little bit of soy sauce
a little bit of sesame seeds then we top
it off with some snap peas some cucumber
avocado a little mayo and my favorite
gochujang
okay don't rip into me in the comment
section because I have failed learning
how to use chopsticks properly I just
usually
struggle my way through it and if
something eventually gets in my mouth
it's like a bonus that's what she said
right that's probably good guys
Mercury's in retrograde and I'm
constantly moving losing there you go
we're gonna be here all day folks if I
attempt to eat my lunch with these
Chopsticks so we'll swap those out for
Handy Dandy spoon poppy you're not gonna
like this it's a little spicy girl she's
willing to take the risk but we've got
lots of protein in our salmon healthy
fats in the avocado plus tons of fiber
in our veg avocado kimchi all the good
things oh I'm excited about this like I
don't know how I put off making this for
so long I got a little overzealous on
the rice to seaweed ratio here it might
be a little bit of a messy Endeavor oh
my God okay God's takes Abby just
concentrate I swear if I put my mind to
it I can do it it just takes a lot of
effort
and I'd rather just concentrate on the
eating
mmm
Brown kimchi but
if for your gut
kimchi is a traditional Korean fermented
cabbage condiment that contains natural
lactobacillus probiotics which we know
is linked to improve gut health mental
health heart health and so much more
it's one of the proposed reasons why
South Koreans have one of the longest
life expectancies in the world that said
if colonizing the gut is the goal it's
important to know that not all fermented
foods contain enough microbes to qualify
as a probiotic in other words it's
unlikely you'd be getting a clinical
dose of lactobacillus bacteria from
having a few pieces of cabbage on your
rice that said kimchi is flavorful low
calorie high fiber and nutrient packed
which may explain its association with
reduced body fat BMI and blood sugar
levels so while it may not replace a
probiotic supplement it's an excellent
addition to any meal let's talk snack
which I'll be honest I'm kind of less
than jazzed about because according to
multiple sources both Lisa and Jenny
drink detox juice every day unless
you're fresh newbie here you guys know
that you don't need some kind of nasty
juice to detox any juice is mainly water
and water makes you pee AKA detox and if
a juice speeds up said detox it's likely
because it's so full of fodmaps or other
gut irritants that it gives you the runs
so for more pleasant detoxing experience
I'm gonna have some water oh natural and
I'm gonna add a source of fiber to help
move the old bowels apparently jisoo
really likes red fruit and raspberries
are one of the best sources of dietary
fiber so it's a great option if you want
to detox AKA poop
also before you get started at me in the
comments no I'm not going to make this
no hunger crushing combo I am still
pretty satrated from the two big meals
that I just had I mean they're really
hearty they definitely hit the spot and
this is really all that I need
um
[Music]
do dogs like raspberries
let's find out
well she's not begging for more so I
think we have our answer
all right lovers talk dinner to me so
based on my very unscientific research
jisoo loves dumplings and Lisa loves
noodle dishes like Pad Thai both
favorites of mine but I figured we would
use this opportunity to experiment with
some more Korean ingredients so instead
of pad thai we're gonna make these
denjung noodles which I pulled some
inspiration from reading a bunch of
blogs online they look absolutely
amazing and I'm super excited to try it
let's do it let's cook up some soba
noodles
steam some frozen dumplings
might as well do them all
a little bit of avocado oil a little
garlic ginger gonna add some extra from
tofu
add in some veg
[Music]
now let's make the sauce so denjang is
fermented Korean soybean paste that's
kind of like miso but a little bit
funkier
so we're gonna put that down add a
little water yes I know it looks like a
turd in a toilet pool but stay with me
little rice wine vinegar sesame oil
gochujang or Sriracha maple syrup and
some cornstarch to thicken
now we gotta carefully
emulsify
all right add in our sauce
[Music]
and add our buckwheat noodles I am so
excited about this we have protein in
our tofu and in the chicken dumplings
we've got lots of fiber in the soba
noodles plus all the veg and healthy
fats in the peanuts and sesame oil that
sauce
holy is good and since Rose has
been quoted as saying she specifically
avoids spicy food before shoot stating
if I'm hungry at night I just endure it
as long as I can and then not eat
anything at all I went in extra spicy
oh I love the peanuts that my friends is
a juicy dumpling
and that brings me to dessert so while I
was doing research for this video I was
reading a ton of different Korean food
blogs trying to get some inspiration and
I read that traditionally Korean meals
don't always end with desserts as they
do in North America there are definitely
Korean desserts but that's not the
expectation like it is here so I guess
all the reports that these girls just
have like apples or fruit as their
snacks do check out even though of
course it feels very restrictive in the
context of a day like this that said a
lone Apple for dessert is giving mad
Kylie Jenner Vibes I lock myself in my
bedroom and I turn on my TV I get really
comfortable and I pre-slice an apple and
I'm also still pretty full from dinner
so instead I got these cult classic
Malona bars these are apparently a
staple in Korea and we've been eating
them for years and I didn't even know
that my kids love them I love them they
taste so good the mango is my favorite
but the melon is also really tasty and
they're big
no they're not really big it's not the
size that matters it's what you do with
it
and again folks not every meal or snack
needs to be a hunger crushing combo
sometimes sugary fruit water just hits
the spot these are delicious why are you
laughing Brody it's like zero way about
looking like not sexual I know I know I
like the square shape
okay
okay super fun obviously you know it was
putting myself up to the challenge of
exploring different cultural flavors and
traditional foods and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video please give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like me to try
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen and
y'all
foreign foreign